[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici l'heure des amis Mania on
a un max
[Musique]
on IR on SAU notre
pour mais pourquoi tu fais Simp de
zapper c'est des images qu'on a monté
nous ah bah oui ça explique pourquoi il
y a sandy Valentino en tête des ventes
enfin bref salut tout le monde avant de
commencer cette vidéo on va faire un
petit retour sur le sujet précédent vous
vous en souvenez j'avais parlé de dessin
animé pour filles et notamment j'avais
parlé de Magical Girl mais est-ce que
vous vous êtes déjà demandé comment
finissait un dessin animé de magical
girl moi non plus mais pourtant je vais
quand même vous en parler on va parler
notamment de crimie hein vous vous en
souvenez les culottes les
extraterrestres et cetera et bien dans
le dernier épisode de la série les
extraterrestres les mêmes qu'au début
reviennent donc pour reprendre les
pouvoirs de crimy qui je rappelle
n'était qu'en CDD de 1 an non
renouvelable et ça en plein milieu de
son concert devant des gens qui n'ont
leur absolument pas choqué par tous les
trucs complètement hallucinants qui se
passent autour
[Applaudissements]
d'eux euh la chanteuse vient de s'en
voler
là euh la chanteuse vient d'être
désintégrée non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non rien du tout la seule réaction des
gens devant la désintégration de la
chanteuse en direct et l'arrivée d'un
vaisseau spatial alienne c'est de
réclamer la chanson
suivante bref crimy elle elle est de
retour sur le vaisseau et elle essaie de
convaincre l'extraterrestre de la
laisser finir sa dernière chanson
celui-ci ne veut pas mais est-ce que
cette fille est une psychopathe sérieux
elle a essayé de le tuer la première
fois qu'elle vu elleessaie de le tuer au
bout de 2 minutes de conversation bon
bref finalement il accepte après cette
tentative de meurtre évidemment et
revoit la crimie qui aur bien chanter sa
chanson finale amour je con tiens vous
avez vu il y a un baisseau spaal mais
merde et ainsi fini crimy alors ça c'est
un exemple de magical girl plutôt sympa
maintenant j'ai un autre exemple la fin
de Gigi aujourd'hui on a tendance à
trouver que les dessins animés sont trop
superficiels peut-être qu'à l'époque
ilétait pas assez
OK
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez tous avec
moi
j
Ji oui c'est vrai c'est bien bien
fini sous le
con il y a une petite fille il en reste
que du
Hai c'est toi
Jigi non sans déconner ce dessin animé
passé le matin juste avant d'aller à
l'école je te laisse imaginer comment
après ça tu as le peps pour la journée
piston c'est l'heure d'aller à l'école
fais attention en traversant la route
alors cela dit la série a continué quand
même après cet épisode puisque Gigi se
réincarne dans un bébé après une espèce
de montage sous-acide complètement
incompréhensible tiens regardez je vous
présente mes vrais parents parce qu'en
fait vous êtes pas mes vrais parents mes
vrais parents c'est des sorciers deun
monde magique mais oui rentrz on va
fumer des pétardes tous ensemble bref
rien de mieux que la mort d'une magical
girl pour commencer cette vidéo parce
que cette vidéo elle est pour vous les
hommes les vrais et les dures ceux qui
ont du poil ceux qui en ont dans le
pantalon ceux qui ont le service trois
pièces le zigoui la bistouquette le
canon chargé bref salut les mecs cette
vidéo elle est pour vous cigarette ah
non merci j'ai arrêté tu as tort parce
que c'est vachement bon bref vous l'avez
compris après le spécial dessin animé
pour filles c'est l'heure du spécial
dessin animé pour mec
lent
euh non enfin bref donc pour récapituler
il existe plusieurs grandes catégories
de dessin animés alors il y a ce pour
fille dont on a déjà parlé il y a les
dessins animés éducatifs type le bus
magique où il était une fois la vie par
exemple qu'on verra une autre fois les
dessins animés jeunesse qui peuvent être
regardés par n'importe qui la bande
Pixou Inspecteur Gadget par exemple
c'est le plus grand boss de toute la
ville et les dessins animés pour garçons
mais sachez cependant qu'il existe
plusieurs types de dessin animés pour
garçons on a d'un côté le dessin animé
japonais pour garçons c'est-à-dire le
shonen avec les sous-genres les dessins
animés avec des combats les dessins
animés sportifs les dessin animé avec
des petites culottes bref et on a le
dessin animé pour garçon occidental
complètement différent puis parce que là
le but est souvent et je dira même
exclusivement dans 99 % des cas de
vendre un jouet puisque ces séries ne
sont faites que pour appuyer la vente
d'un jouet ce système pour vendre des
jouets ça a toujours existé autant pour
les dessins animés que pour les films
comme par exemple avec les les jouets
Jurassic Park voilà ça sert à rien de
vous les montrer mais comme je suis trop
fier de les avoir je vous les montre et
mais pour les dessins animés c'était pas
pareil parce que pour les gens de ma
génération tu n'achetis un jouet que
parce qu'il avait son propre dessin
animé prenez le cas de Dino riders une
série avec des dinosaures qui tire des
rayons laser tu le sens bien là le
concept fait par des commerciaux
franchement ou Jo par exemple ça c'est
la pure série américaine qui n'a aucun
autre but que de vendre des jouets je
veux dire sorti des beaux jouets qu'on
te montre tout au long des épisodes faut
clairement pas s'attendre à avoir un
scénario làdedans devenir cosmonaut avec
J cet aquarium devrait suffire ah oui
les sac pouBell devrai apporte une
protection satisfaisante attrape ça mais
j'ai pensé que ce serait parfait pour te
propulser une fois làdedans oui comme
ça et c'est comme ça qu'on va dans
l'espace la prochaine fois les enfants
avec un poubon en plastique un pot de
crème fraîche semiépaisse et une VHS de
speed 2 nous voyagerons dans le
temps cette série je me souviens que
j'arrivais pas à prendre le méchant au
sérieux mais je me souviens plus
pourquoi formidable c'est le moment de
profiter de notre avantage attaquer tout
ané
antis bataillon d'androïde enavour
ok je m'en souviens maintenant enfin bon
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque j Jo cette
série c'était vraiment la série pour
garçon c'était l'incarnation de la série
pour mec quand tu regardais la série tu
te disais
c'est super vérile ça c'est des vrais
mecs alors que quand tu regardes les
personnages avec un peu de recul ben ça
fait vraiment cuir cuir cuir moustache
enfin bref j'aurais bien plein de trucs
à dire et de Vanes à faire sur cette
série non attends c'est imprudent mais
tu sais bien qu'il faut toujours garder
réserv mais malheureusement j'ai dépassé
mon quotat de blague sur les gay pour
cette année donc finalement à la place
on va parler de
[Musique]
masque bon donc alors masque ça veut
dire mobile Armor strike commande mais
comme masque avec un c ça voulait rien
dire finalement donc ils l'ont écrit
avec un K ce qui fait qu'il y a une méga
faute d'orthographe dans leur logo mais
bon c'est pas grave donc masque c'est
quoi présentation
[Musique]
B bienvenue au mosque on fait des né des
lumières avec du
tuning camions
pu la moto moi je de la
voiture
Rob je comprends pas voilà
[Musique]
et plus sérieusement donc masque combat
Venom ce qui veut dire vicius evil
network of meum le vicieux diabolique
réseau de meum je pense que c'est les
méchants l'épisode 1 de masque commence
donc par un météorite qui tombe sur
terre et qui évolé par des méchants mais
alors la jeune journaliste poursuivie
par ces derniers qui pensait l'avoir tué
se réveille alors dans la chambre du
héros mat tracker qui décide de
convoquer le masque afin de retrouver la
météorite sélectionne les agents de
masque les plus aptes à remplir cette
mission et là ce que vous allez voir
c'est la plus belle manière que j'ai
jamais vu dans un dessin animé de gagner
une minute par épisode puisque ça
revient absolument à chaque fois
personnel sélectionn BR Turner pilote de
moto et d'hélicoptère nom de code
[Musique]
Condor ingénieur spécialiste en
mécanique n de code
Rino Alex sector expert en informatique
et communication responsable du réseau
Rino mais c'est quoi ces [ __ ]
d'irresponsable là qui laisse tout
tomber dè que leur Monon David Michel
spécialiste en sauvetage et humanitaire
nom de code pas la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peau et puis je veux dire le mec il
bosse avec eux tous les jours il a
vraiment besoin de se retaper leur CV à
chaque fois enfin bon bref donc après
une petite réunion un ascenseur
complètement inutile et un habituel
cliché de tapage de clavier sur des
touches multicolor qui personnellement
m'ont toujours fait rire dans n'importe
quelle série je suis sous le vent non
mais sérieusement il tapent quoi là bleu
bleu jaune bleu bleu et les voilà parti
pour arrêter les méchants c'était facile
il leur suffit juste d'appuyer sur un
gros bouton rose et ça file leur
localisation exacte regardez le voilà
c'est pratique pour le scénario
évidemment on a au passage
l'indispensable élément relou de
l'histoire en la personne de Scott qui
va systématiquement à chaque épisode
ent d'accompagner l'équipe des masqu et
les faire chier en se mettant à mort en
danger et nous avons là le schéma
classique de tous les épisodes de masque
1 méchant volit toujours quelque chose 2
Scott fera forcément un truc idiot 3
respecter les clichés racistes par
exemple s'il y a un asiatique dans la
série il devra forcément s'exprimer par
des trucs du genre chèvre piqu provoque
irrésistiblement l'appétit du
tigre
qu
explosion le laser la voiture qui crache
de feu laser achète la voiture la bouton
elle est trop cool et 5 penser à finir
par un rire collectif idiot suivi d'une
morale à la fin de l'épisode du genre
viens ici mon vieux viens te faire
carasser attention Scott tu connais ce
chien ah non pas du tout mais il a l'air
vraiment gentil il faut faire attention
il pourrait te mordre tu sais n'oublie
pas que lui non plus ne te connaît pas
et ça alors qu'il a passé tout l'épisode
à se faire tirer dessus un coup de
missile c'est vrai que masque c'est
quand même une série qui assez mal
vieilli je trouve les personnages sont
plats les intrigues c'est toujours les
mêmes et le truc qui m'énervait c'est
que les mecs ils ont beau être à des
endroits complètement perdus sur la
planète masque et Venom vont toujours se
tomber dessus par hasard à tel point
qu'à un moment ça devient vraiment
franchement ridicule quoi au feu rouge à
Las Vegas c'est Venom dans une fête
foraine à la nouvelle orléand Venom au
milieu de Tokyo Venom ça va ça dev un
sketch à un moment quoi
Venom
Venom donc passons au deème type de
dessin animé pour garçons les shonen
donc des shonen il y en a plein desbz
les chevel zodiaque nickyarson fly Oliv
Tom one pace derrière il y a toujours
une notion d'atteindre un but ultime que
ce soit battre le méchant devenir le
meilleur dresseur de Pokémon devenir le
roi des pirates peu importe bref et il y
a aussi pas toujours mais il y en a
quand même une notion de progression du
héros comme par exemple dans overdrive
le mec à l'épisode 1 il s'est pas monté
sur un vélo et à l'épisode 26 il les
maillots jaunes du Tour de France voilà
ou Oliv Tom avec le Japon qui finit
champion du monde heureusement qu'ils
ont les animés les Japonais parce que
sinon il gagnera rien du tout
[Musique]
hein de toute façon comprenez que faire
un shonen c'est pas compliqué je veux
dire tu prends n'importe quel concept je
sais pas nouer C lac poster des lettres
tiens poster des lettres un shonen sur
la poste donc déjà il faut un bon titre
avec un opening facile à retenir
ensuite dans un B il faut forcément un
vieux maître desases qui n' aucun sens
le vent porte la beauté du courrier dans
les fleurs de C risier affranchtoi du
poid de ton â et l de la vie qui après
pour le reste contentezvous juste de
remplir avec des random trucs pi dans
d'autres animés et ça passera très bien
[Musique]
ne fais pas ça cette technique est
interdite le col n'est pas
assuré ce col passera jamais la BO trop
petite il est complètement fou je fais
Vanger la mort de mon père tué par un
camion
[Applaudissements]
FedEx le chon est par définition pour
garçon puisque shonen ça veut dire
adolescent de sexe masculin mais on
retrouve aussi parfois certains chojo
c'est-à-dire des dessins animés pour
filles qui utilisent des codes du shonen
c'est leur Moon les écolières en
minijupe c'était pas les filles que ça
attirit c'était les mecs et d'ailleurs
on retrouve aussi parfois des notions de
shonen dans des trucs un peu plus
exotiques comme comme ça par
exemple il s'agit du générique japonais
de la série dont je vais vous parler et
vous l'aurez tous compris en voyant ces
images nous allons parler de de théâtre
[Musique]
voilà donc Laura ou la passion du
théâtre c'est justement un dessin animé
censé être pour filles mais qui utilise
des codes de dessin animé pour mecs et
ça vaut le coup d'œil croyez-moi donc
ben c'est l'histoire de Laura qui veut
faire non pas du son longueur comme le
laisse penser le générique mais du
théâtre et si j'en parle c'est que cette
série va trop loin MIM l'oiseau qui
regagne sa cage oui
[Musique]
monsieur on dirait vraiment qu' il y a
un oiseau avec elle c'est
fantastique l'oiseau vient de se poser
sur son doigt c'est comme si je le
voyais c'est extraordinaire
oui ça va trop loin tous les personnages
dans cette série sont complètement
shootés à mort donc l'histoire c'est une
intro classique elle travaille dans un
restaurant mais un jour lors d'une
livraison elle tombe sur Chloé de CEN
fiacre que j'appellerai madame gros plan
sur mon œil parce que c'est moins cher à
animer et qu'il apprend dans son école
de théâtre alors dans l'épisode suivant
on rentre de suite dans le vif du sujet
Laura doit jouer le rôle de B dans la
pièce des quatre filles du docteur March
mais il se trouve qu'elle doit jouer le
rôle d'une fille malade et qu'elle
n'arrive pas bien à le faire et donc
puisque c'est un animé japonais la
meilleure solution c'est toujours la
plus simple je vais rester sous la pluie
et je serai malade et je pourrais enfin
être le personnage de
[Applaudissements]
bête et voilà donc Laura dehors sous la
pluie qui attend d'être malade à en
crever jusqu'à se faire récupérer par le
directeur d'une troupe de théâtre
concurrente qui passait par là et qui a
détecté
sa je sais pas sa cosmoénergie on dirait
c'est quoi ce plan là enfin bref donc il
détecte sa cosmoénergie et la voilà
malade à en crever avec 41 de fièvre
elle a une très forte fièvre mais on
s'en fout qu'elle est failli crever on
est au Japon l'important c'est la pièce
de théâtre cette fois elle possède
vraiment le personnage
de prochaine pièce de théâtre on fait
une adaptation sur scène de la mort de
Gigi tu sais ce qui te reste à faire
allez de Bou c'est ce que j'aime dans
cette série c'est que tu rigoles tout le
temps tellement que les personnages sont
prêts à crever littéralement pour leur
pièce à la con à l'épisode 5 la
directrice de la troupe de théâtre
enferme Laura dans une cabane sans eau
ni nourriture en plein hiver avec une
vitre cassée pour la punir parce qu'elle
ne joue pas assez bien un rôle je ne
pense pas que ça soit légal et ensuite
Laura et Madame de Saint Fiacre qui est
venu l'aider dans le froid à répéter
alors qu'il y a le studio juste à côté
pour le faire reste pendant
le 5è jour le combat toucha à sa fin et
quel combat bordel de merde c'est du
théâtre de toute façon c'est un animé
japonais quoi que tu fasse le public il
sera à
fond non mais je sais pas vous avez déjà
vu des gens dans un théâtre comme ça n
sont tous très attentifs qu'est-ce qui
se
passe venez on va regarder la lanterne
magique regardez elle s assise c'est
incroyable comment est-ce qu'elle a fait
non vraiment moi je vous conseille de
regarder cet animée e pour des moments
comme ça madame de Saint Fiacre
parlez-moi du personnage de la princesse
écarlate est-ce que vous croyez qu'un
jour je serai capable d'interpréter un
roule aussi difficile et aussi complexe
que celui-là Laura tu dois essayer de
devenir un arbre allez vite essaie
d'être un arbre
oui
Laura est-ce que tu as déjà vu un arbre
qui bouge et qui crie
psychopathe sérieusement j'adore ce
personnage de Madame de sien fiacre
c'est une [ __ ] de psycho en puissance
plus loin dans l'épisode alors que Laura
s'entraîne à boîter pour jouer le rôle
d'une handicapé qui c'est qui est
là madame de saia
[Musique]
Laura comment crois-tu qu'il te soit
possible de te déplacer avec une jambe
paralysée je ne sais pas vous m'avez
fait mal madame vous l'avez fait exprès
psychopathe alors mais pourtant on est
quand même très très loin du délire
maximal sur la possibilité de
l'exagération des chonenes hein je vous
avais montré dans le premierre hor série
sur les animé un très court extrait du
Petit Chef alors revenons-y un peu pour
rappel le petit chef c'est l'histoire
d'un garçon nommé Thomas qui rêve de
devenir cuisinier alors vous vous
rappeler de Colissimo noensu et bien le
générique japonais c'est presque
[Musique]
ça c'est violent la cuisine [ __ ] bref
dans l'épisode 1 monsieur Gaspar
savoureux tel est son Excellence Gaspar
savoureux merci la VF critique culinaire
donc va déjeuner dans le restaurant de
Thomas par hasard après avoir pris un
mauvais repas dans un grand restaurant
de luxe et là Thomas décide de
l'impressionner en lui faisant un bon
repas attrapez
ça l'auberge nouvelle spécialité de
coquette de viande oui au Japon c'est
comme ça qu'on vous donnera le menu mais
attendez là c'est rien là parce que
Gaspar savoureux va
prendre Gaspar savoureux comment tu veux
faire une scène sérieuse avec un nom
comme ça va mon enfant confiance en moi
après tout ne suis-je pas Gaspard
savoureux bref Gaspard savoureux va
prendre là le meilleur repas de sa
[Musique]
vie c'est
incroyable qui fait un plat qui
déchire alors ça ça n'est rien hein
sérieusement comparé au reste de la
série ça n'est rien du tout il y a juste
un peu de lumière suite à ce spectacle
son et lumière Gaspar savoureux l'invite
donc à le rencontrer dans ses bureaux
mais Thomas se perd et arrive par hasard
dans le cours de cuisine de Mario un
cuisinier Italien spécialisé dans les
patttes W
[Musique]
humilié par le petit chef qui a
découvert l'incroyable secret de mesurer
le temps de cuisson marqué au dos du
paquet Mario décide alors de défier
Thomas en duel de de de pâte pour lui
prouver ben que c'est le meilleur hein
mais enfin Mario vous ne trouvez pas que
cé un peu plusile de vouloir vous
mesurer à cet enfant n'oubliez pas que
italien il pas pas
[Musique]
d'honneur bref nous voilà parti pour un
duel de
carte attends non pardon c'est juste un
concours de cuisine ultra exagéré voilà
c'est ça et donc on va assister au
premier défilé de réaction totalement
exagérée pour une simple cuisson de pâte
il est faux mais qu'est-ce
fait imbcile qu'est-ce qui t'a c'est une
impardonnableavoir coup les spaghettis
on ne pourra plus les autour de la fouch
tu as complètement perdu laête c'est la
je'en
supp on sen qu'il coupé ses P [ __ ] et
attention faut voir la réaction du jury
quand il goûte le plat c'est délicieux
c'est vraiment fantastique c'est
excellent extraordinaire
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
goûte un plat pareil la présentation est
originale et le goût est tout à fait
merveilleux qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
cet animé sérieusement dirait que les
mec vient de se prendre une attaque des
Chevaliers du Zodiaque
[Musique]
[Rires]
regarde y
[Musique]
en fait le petit chef c'est une série de
combat mais avec de la bouffe sans
déconner on y retrouve tous les codes
d'une série de combat sérieusement
[ __ ] vous avez déjà vu Ken le
Survivant faire des sushis moi oui
épisode 32 c'est parti
[Musique]
non mais c'est génial [ __ ] chaque fois
que tu te dis que ça peut pas aller plus
loin c'est encore mieux et puis
attention faut voir les réaction des
gens quand il goûtent la cuisine de Thas
c'est limite si tu regardes pas la série
que pour ça tellement c'est n'importe
quoi à chaque fois il y a la
transformation en super
Saen j'ai trouvé attention il va exposer
je sais à quoi est l'osité de la sauce
de elle est à la moutarde mélangé à une
purée de carot
c'est la catastrophe ce que je redoutis
est
arrivé
pourê et cette saveur qui dégage ça vous
met l' à laouche oui ce sont des gens
qui surfent sur des sushis ah
quel régal félicitation
[Musique]
cette omelette a la légèreté d'un
papillon qui s revle c'est vraiment un
délice et puis elle est si moelleuse non
mais ce mec il met de l'extasie dans ses
places c'est pas possible tu imagin si
le moindre petit truc que tu bouffais te
faisait faire un
[Musique]
p